We hope you're near the Mos Eisley Cantina,
because you'll definitely need to unwind after
hearing this head-spinning new Star Wars theory.
"Welcome, young Skywalker!"
Over at Screen Rant, writer Thomas Bacon has
published a theory centered around Emperor
Palpatine, the Sith Lord who rose through
the ranks of the Galactic Republic to become
its Emperor before Darth Vader took him out
in Return of the Jedi by launching him into
the Death Star's reactor.
Or, at least, that's what we thought happened.
The vicious villain is slated to make a jaw-dropping
comeback in writer-director J.J. Abrams' The
Rise of Skywalker.
Palpatine's signature cackle was heard in
the first trailer, and his presence could
be felt in the final pre-release footage for
the film, when Daisy Ridley's Rey stood opposite
a dark figure.
Many have speculated as to what Emperor Palpatine's
role in The Rise of Skywalker will be, without
accounting for how he would even be alive
to return and wreak havoc in the first place.
Now, Bacon has presented a theory apparently
crafted by many other Star Wars fans as to
how the character survived his apparent death-by-the-Death-Star.
The idea goes that Emperor Palpatine didn't
really die when Darth Vader, overcome with
emotion while watching Palpatine attack and
torture his son Luke Skywalker with Force
lightning, chucked him into the Death Star's
reactor.
Rather, it's believed that Palpatine transformed
himself into Force energy to survive the fall
into the reactor.
And that energy blast may not have been a
release of Dark Side energy as traditionally
believed, but instead Palpatine himself in
his new Force energy form.
How exactly might have Emperor Palpatine rid
himself of his mortal body and turned himself
into intangible Force energy?
The theory points to the in-universe legends
collection Star Wars: Myths & Fables, which
contains a story called "Gaze of Stone."
The story involves a Sith Lord apprentice
performing a ritual that transforms flesh.
His plan went sideways, however, when the
ritual was turned against him, and he was
turned into rock.
According to this new theory, Emperor Palpatine
used a Sith ritual similar to this one to
escape death at the end of Return of the Jedi.
Palpatine's preoccupation with immortality
is an important foundation of this theory,
as the ensuing details claim that Palpatine
built his Throne Rooms like the one within
the Death Star in a way that would allow him
to "amplify his power" and "transform into
an energy state rather than die."
It isn't out of the realm of possibility that
Emperor Palpatine, fearful of dying and losing
power over the galaxy, would call upon a Sith
enchantment to cheat death.
However, there's a big snag in this theory:
it doesn't explain how Palpatine would then
return to his physical form pale skin, haunting
eyes, and all to stir up trouble in The Rise
of Skywalker.
Many have turned to Chuck Wendig's Star Wars:
Aftermath novels for a possible solution.
The books feature a Sith cultist and former
adviser to Emperor Palpatine who attempts
a ceremony within one of the Emperor's Throne
Rooms in an attempt to revive Palpatine and
restore his body.
The ceremony fails in the novel, but could
someone else carry out a similar ceremony
in The Rise of Skywalker and place Palpatine
back in his corporeal form?
Anything's possible in the Star Wars universe,
but the ritual-performer would have to be
someone extremely devoted to the dark side
and the advancement of the First Order who
would genuinely want to see the Emperor return
to the throne.
An obvious choice would be Kylo Ren, the emotionally-unbalanced
villain who may be suffering a crisis of confidence
and faith in the upcoming movie.
Plus, there have been a ton of rumors suggesting
that Kylo Ren will abandon the dark side and
his villainous moniker before the end of The
Rise of Skywalker, reclaiming his birth name
of Ben Solo to complete his redemption arc.
A potentially faltering First Order baddie
isn't exactly the kind of candidate one would
select to resurrect Emperor Palpatine and
bring about what's probably going to be the
most intense First-Order-versus-Resistance
battle the galaxy has ever seen.
Unless, of course, Kylo revives him for the
sole purpose of killing him for good this
time.
Fans will have to try to keep their minds
from running wild with unconfirmed theories,
and patiently wait until The Rise of Skywalker
opens in theaters on December 20 to learn
the truth.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.